toi
[Musique]
et moi savons que c'est de l'amour, cet endroit
pourrait être bien meilleur que juillet,
n'est-ce pas
[Musique] [
Musique]
pardonne-moi d'
essayer de voir dans cette pièce que nous ne pouvons pas
ressentir n'a pas arrêté de nettoyer la saleté
aime toujours assez loin toi  est-ce que
[Musique]
me
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
briller [
Musique] pour
ainsi dire [
Musique]
ces ajouts dans ce monde, la Russie, nous
pourrions vraiment y arriver si vous vous souciez
suffisamment de croire que faire des mètres, c'est
faire mieux
[Musique]
fais-en un meilleur endroit pour toi et pour
moi
[Musique]
[Musique] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
toi toi